in order to reach your potential and do
what you're really meant to do you're
gonna need some help you can't do this
alone
you need coaching to do it you need
feedback and you need people to talk to
about your fears your insecurities your
doubts sometimes you just need people to
talk to you for a reality check the
thing that struck me really struck me
and shook me when I came here to Harvard
Business School is I would have a
student come to my office and really
talk to me about a difficult situation
they're going through and the first
question I normally ask them is who's
you talk to about it and invariably the
answer is almost always no one and what
I've realized is in this hyper connected
world we live in people don't have that
many relationships relationship means
mutual trust mutual respect and mutual
understanding there's an exercise in
three things I think you can do to help
build understanding trust and respect
and that is self disclosure in order to
have a relationship someone and have
them understand you you have to tell
them something about yourself and I
don't mean something superficial I mean
something fundamental about yourself
maybe your upbringing your parents
traumas in your life something that
would help them understand you better
and a lot of people are so buttoned up
they don't ever do that number two and
when I say I call it inquiry which means
asking someone a question that would
help you understand them better how many
times does a senior person of the
company take a trip with it with
subordinates and they don't learn a damn
thing about them in the entire business
trip because they never asked they never
ask just ask questions a lot of us are
not good at that and then the third
thing is do you seek advice you frame a
situation that you want advice on or an
area of self-doubt and ask advice just
think how great you feel when somebody
tries to seek your advice on something I
feel flattered they're showing me a lot
of respect now why do I suggest doing
those three things they help people
understand you better they help you
understand the person you're trying to
have a relationship better they build
trust and
those three things help build
relationships and the reason I go
through this in this book you need to
have relationships with people you can't
be an island and more often than not I
find when people are struggling in their
lives or have regrets this is one
ingredient that they failed to to work
on and so I'm trying to talk about how
do you build a relationship so that you
can actually go to work on doing it